Hi, Mystery Recapped here. Today I am going to
explain an American prison comedy film called “Big
Stan”. Spoilers ahead! Watch out and take care!
Stan Minton is a real estate agent living in LA,
who has everything he wants in life; he is filthy
rich and has a beautiful wife Mindy who he loves.
Stan has a unique way of selling properties to his
clients. He usually cheats them of a small amount
which has over the years grown large. Hence,
one day, he is arrested for first-degree fraud.
He is found guilty and is told that he will get
a sentence of at least three years in prison.
Desperate to find a way out, he asks his lawyer to
bribe the judge. The lawyer does as told but the
conviction is absolute. By faking a charity event,
he only manages to get Stan six months free time
before being imprisoned. After the hearing,
the lawyer suggests Stan take a long trip
to Brazil to never return. But he cannot do
so because all his assets have been frozen.
Stan has no way but to live the next few
months in fear of what is about to come.
Starting that day, he does everything quicker
because of the limited time. One evening,
he is on a date with Mindy who wants to have a
kid so she won’t be alone when he is gone. Stan
thinks the idea is absurd because they will have
to give up the kid for adoption when he returns.
He dreads the idea of having children which
creates a rift in his relationship with his wife.
Mindy storms off after his comment while Stan
drives to a bar at random. While drinking, he
notices a man beside him with a tattoo about going
to prison. He asks the guy for tips on prison
life and offers him a hundred bucks to talk.
The man starts by saying that the prison guards
do not care about the inmates and their fights.
The prisoners could kill each other but as long
as they don’t escape they let you do anything.
He also adds that Stan looks like someone who
would most definitely be sexually violated by
the inmates. Stan realizes that all the rumors
about men turning gay in prison are true.
He is weak and submissive which makes him
the perfect target. When the man suggests he
get several tattoos to avoid being targeted,
Stan shows him a tattoo of his mother on his arm
which clearly won’t work. The man then advises
him to join one of the groups in the prison. The
groups are mostly divided into Nazis, racists,
Mexican men, and African American men. But since
Stan doesn’t fit in any of those categories,
his last resort is to kill someone so
the inmates would be scared of him.
The following morning, he wakes up with a hangover
and thinks that he was dreaming. He is distressed
when Mindy tells him he is still going to prison.
To uplift him, she mentions his special quality
is that he always finds a way. This encourages
Stan and he makes it his mission to become an
alpha in the next six months. Starting the next
day exercises every day and gets a tattoo on his
behind to make it less attractive. One night, Stan
asks Mindy to use a sex toy on him so even if the
inmates try to take advantage of him, he would
be accustomed to it. He also joins a karate class
but is bored when asked to learn the basics. He
challenges the teacher and gets in a fight with
one of the kids which results in him being thrown
out of the establishment. This is when he meets an
old man named The Master. He impresses Stan by
breaking a hole in the wall with no effort.
He is Stan’s only hope to learn self-defense
before going to prison. Hence, he brings the old
man home to train with him. The Master starts
living with them, much to Mindy’s annoyance.
On his first day of training, Stan is woken up at
five in the morning by blood from an animal liver
pouring on his face. Then, the master makes
Mindy blend ox pancreas and horse tongues to
make a smoothie for her husband. His way of
training is different and over the top, some
days he hits Stan with a flaming stick, while the
other days he hangs him by his skin to test his
endurance. He also feeds Stan a variety of weird
food like scorpions and snakes. Mindy, who is
tired of the master smoking all around the house,
asks her husband to get rid of him. That night,
Stan pretends that they are being robbed and makes
Mindy think she is about to be sexually assaulted.
It turns out he is doing this to make her feel
what he is feeling. When Mindy stops panicking,
she packs her luggage and leaves, claiming that
she doesn’t want to be with him anymore.
The Master is delighted that she left because
with only men in the house, the training can get
tougher. For the next five months, Stan works hard
without resting. By the end of it, he manages to
take the master by surprise in combat. For
his last test, he goes to fight the karate
teacher who once threw him out of his class. Stan
defeats the man easily and completes his training.
He is finally ready to defend himself when he
needs to. The master and the lawyer drop him off
at the court. Mindy has still not talked to him
but she watches him secretly from inside her car.
Stan finally goes inside and is transported to
the prison on a bus. Immediately, a guy tries
to touch him inappropriately but Stan teaches
him a lesson. At the prison, they are welcomed
by warden Gasque who kindly asks them to not
trouble the guards, but other than that, they
can do anything they please to each other.
During the cavity check, the new inmates are asked
to strip and bend over. The guards are horrified
to see Stan’s behind that he has modified to make
it look unpleasant. Following the cavity check,
he goes to his cell and meets his roommate Larry.
To assert his dominance, he asks Larry to get
to the lower bunk. Later, Larry tells him about
the prison squads who have basically formed a
gang. The first gang is a group of black men,
the second one is a team of Mexican thugs, the
third one is Nazis, and the fourth one is racists.
Then, there is a group of scientists who are great
at killing people by talking too much. Lastly,
he is introduced to the most dangerous sexual
predator of the block; Big Raymond.
Raymond is terrorizing a new inmate when Stan
approaches him and challenges him in front of
everyone. They get into a fight where Stan uses
self-defense techniques taught by the master
to beat him easily. Impressed by his
skills, the leader of the nazi group,
Patterson tries to invite him to their
team but Stan beats him up as well.
Then, he is approached by the African American
team who are furious that he fought Big Raymond.
Stan tries to avoid the fight claiming that he is
also black. However, the leader orders his team
to attack, and a fight breaks. The guards enjoy
the show while Stan defeats them efficiently.
After the commotion, the entire prison is afraid
of Stan. People make way for him everywhere he
goes. They all establish him as the alpha of the
prison and call him Big Stan. A young guy named
Robbie who he saved from Raymond earlier comes
to thank him. But Stan dismisses him, claiming
that he didn’t fight those guys for anyone other
than himself. Later, Warden Gasque calls Stan to
his office and reveals that he pushed some buttons
to get Stan in this specific prison. It turns out
that Gasque is planning to take over the prison
property and build an estate. Since Stan is an
experienced realtor, he wants his help to find
out any flaw in the documents relating to it.
In turn for his help, Stan is offered to be freed
only after a year of imprisonment. The idea piques
his interest and he agrees to help. He asks Gasque
how he is going to get rid of the prison, but the
warden wants to keep that part a secret.
In the meantime, the groups of inmates have
joined hands to teach Stan a lesson. While he is
showering one day, Patterson attacks him with a
knife made out of a melted toothbrush and a razor
blade. In turn, Stan brings out his nunchaku made
of soap bars and a shoelace. He easily beats
Patterson up and sends him to the hospital.
Stan misses his wife desperately and wants to
meet her. He contacts his lawyer to see if she
has sent him the divorce papers. To his relief,
she hasn’t yet. After that, he begins to work
on the warden’s project. He is introduced
to a Vietnamese mafia-turned politician,
Dang who is Gasque’s partner on the project
and is helping him sabotage the prison.
Stan overhears them talking about their plan
to get rid of the prison from the property.
He finds out that they are about to make the
inmates fight each other so the guards shoot some
of them. That way, the board of governors will
have to consider closing the prison altogether
because it is not being managed properly.
Stan feels like it is his responsibility to help
the inmates even though they want to kill him.
The following day, he arranges a meeting to set
some rules and boundaries in the prison. Firstly,
he throws away all their violent video games and
movies because they are a bad influence. Then,
he declares sexual assault as a punishable crime;
anyone who does it has to answer to him directly.
When the men whine, he asks them to be involved in
consensual homosexual sex instead. The concept
is new to them but they agree to do it anyway.
During the next lunch break, Robbie and some men
approach Stan’s table and thank him for making
the no assault rules. Stan tries to pass it off as
him asserting dominance but Robbie knows that he
cares about their well-being. At another table,
Big Raymond and his new boyfriend can be seen
enjoying a meal together. They are in a happy
homosexual relationship, thanks to Stan.
Robbie and his group, along with Big Raymond
and his boyfriend, join Stan’s group.
After that, Stan is given a letter addressed to
him by Mindy. He had written to her apologizing
for doing what he did and now, she wants
to meet him. Over the next couple of days,
if anyone gets into an argument, they come to Stan
to solve it. Eventually, everyone starts liking
each other and living in harmony. One day, Mindy
comes to visit Stan, and the two make love. At the
same time, Gasque is informed about what Stan has
been up to. The man is furious at him for solving
the inmate’s conflicts. Stan is dragged away in
the middle of his special time with Mindy.
Gasque calls him out for trying to sabotage
his plan and threatens to make Dang
kill him if he doesn’t follow their orders.
The following day, Stan calls his lawyer to
ask for his opinion. The lawyer suggests he
do as told because Gasque is a powerful man.
After the call, Stan tells everyone that their
problem is not his responsibility and they can
go back to how they were before he came to the
prison. Soon, the fights start to break out again.
Robbie approaches Stan in the cafeteria but he
throws the poor guy’s plate to ask him to go away.
Even Larry is disappointed in him. He tries to
walk away but Stan stops him and asks him to stay
away from the metal fence at noon. Larry realizes
that Stan is being forced into doing something he
doesn’t want to do. He tells all other inmates
about this and they start to plan something.
Meanwhile, Gasque arranges a meeting between
Stan and the parole board to discuss his early
release. While he is in the meeting, Gasque shows
the board of governors around the prison. He plans
to execute the plan at noon near the fence. Since
most of the inmates get into conflicts at noon,
he wants to take the opportunity to kill some
of them while the board members witness it.
Stan pretends to be a horrible person in front of
the parole board to get out of the room and alert
the others to not go near the fence. He is stopped
by Dang who reveals that he has also been trained
by the Master. They get into an intense fight.
Initially, Dang is proven to be more skilled but
Stan takes the lead and knocks Dang out. By
this time, the inmates have already gathered
in the field with weapons. The guards get
ready to shoot them but to their surprise,
the inmates perform a dance number in a Mexican
song. A frustrated Gasque snatches a gun and
fires randomly. The board sees this and is ready
to take action against him. Before going down,
Gasque wants to kill Stan but he is saved by
Mindy. It is revealed that she had been training
with the Master for the past six months.
The scene cuts to three years later. Stan has
finally completed his prison time and is returning
home. His fellow inmates wish them goodbye and
Patterson even gets a tattoo of his face on his
belly. Mindy and the master come to pick him up
with his three-year-old daughter.
Subscribe for more videos like this,
turn on the notification, and leave a like to help
the channel out. Thank You for watching.